[Music]  remember how much fun high school used  to be if you believe that was like 30  years ago  these kids they can be sheltered are so  hot and popular you're like Justin  Bieber if he wasn't like 100 years old  and clueless Bayside is 99% paperless so  getting your books is kind of a pain in  the ass  uh-huh took forever I'm out what did  that blow fool just say to me it may  look like I'm a hot happy guy got a gym  teacher and I saw you eating soup in  their cars  when I was in high school I constantly  used to fight with my best friend over a  girl it was actually your dad over your  mom then I just found another girl that  I really liked and I started hooking up  with her instead oh wait that was your  mom  [Applause]  you